Es wird höchste Zeit mal wieder nach Frankreich zu gucken und zu ihr Frage zu beantworten, was macht eigentlich die Ligue 1? Und diese Frage beantwortet uns David Frogier de Ponlevoy von 93. David, hallo hallo.
Hallo lieber Max.
Sehr schön, dass wir zwei mal wieder miteinander sprechen können. Es wird allerhöchste Zeit. Das letzte Mal haben wir nach dem neunten Spieltag über die Ligue 1 gesprochen. Und jetzt sind, ja gut, je nach Verein, zwischen 22 und 24 Spiele ja schon gespielt in der Liga. Da ist man nicht ganz so konsistent, aber es wird seine Gründe haben. Wir haben so viele Themen, dass ich darüber gar nicht mit dir sprechen wollen würde, sondern dass wir gleich in die Sendung reinstarten.
Wobei, ich muss gleich noch mal reingerätschen, wie ein fieser französischer Verteidiger. Du weißt, warum die so unterschiedliche Spieltage haben, bei den Vereinen.
Also sprich, man hat den alten Trainer dann wieder zurückgeholt, nachdem der neue Trainer in 20 Pflichtspielen hat er 4 Siege geholt nur. Und da sind schon so Dinge dabei, wie im Viertelfinale des einen Pokals 9 zu 8 gegen Rennes. Das dürfte im Elfmeterschießen gewesen sein, ohne dass ich das jetzt näher nachgeguckt habe. Und in der ersten Runde des anderen Pokals mit 1 zu 0. Also sehr, sehr wenig Erfolg. Aber wie kommst du denn dann zu dieser bezaren Situation, dass man den alten Trainer zurückholt?
Weil der alte Trainer eben noch vor Ort war und immer wieder signalisiert hat… Also, Jadim ist kein schlechter Trainer. Jadim ist der Meistertrainer von Monaco. Er ist sicherlich auch ein… Ich halte auch nach wie vor große Stücke auf ihn. Er ist sicherlich auch ein großer Taktiker. Man kann ja auch durchaus sagen, dass die Entlassung tatsächlich zu früh war und dass es eben nicht an ihm lag, sondern dass es an diesem Kader lag. Es ist natürlich insgesamt eine blamabel Situation und es hat noch eine finanzielle Auswirkung. Dieses Trenderkarussell wird Monaco geschätzte 16 bis 20 Millionen Euro gekostet haben. Weil natürlich, als Jadim entlassen wurde, der hatte noch Vertrag bis 2021, der hat eine Entschädigung bekommen von 10 Millionen oder so. Und als Aurie jetzt wieder entlassen wurde, der hatte auch Vertrag bis… Ich weiß nicht wie lange, der hat auch noch mal 8 Millionen Entschädigungen bekommen und dafür noch der gesamte Stuff von Co-Trainer und so weiter. Aurie hatte gerade kurz vorher mit Passi einen Co-Trainer installiert bekommen, weil man sagt, na, vielleicht braucht Aurie einen erfahrenen Trainer nebenan. Also da wurden reihenweise zweimal Leute ausgetauscht.
Ich meine, da muss man jetzt keinen Mitleid haben mit Monaco, dem Verein, der Mbappé, Lemar und Fabinho verkauft hat. Die werden jetzt nicht am Hungertuch nagen, aber es ist natürlich eine interessante Randnotiz und zeigt, wohin es einen führen kann.
Naja, es ist zumindest Geld, dass man auch irgendwie in den Kader stecken könnte stattdessen. Man muss nicht Mitleid haben mit dem Club in Monaco, aber man kann durchaus Mitleid haben mit den Fans, die sich natürlich schon veralbert fühlen. Es gibt eine sehr, sehr kleine, aber durchaus auch spannende Fan- und Ultraszene in Monaco, die da auch so einen gewissen Nationalstolz haben, die sich eben auch als echte Monegassen sehen. Also man ist sehr, sehr verärgert über diesen Verein, über diesen Vorstand. Es ist ja auch in der Zwischenzeit diese ganze Sache passiert. Rübo Loeffleff war ja in die Affäre rund um die Football-Leaks verwickelt, dass er monogassische Polizisten bestochen haben sollen. Der eigentliche Vizier, der agierende Vizier, Vasiliev, da taucht er auf, dass er Mr. 10% genannt wird, weil er bei jedem Transfer immer noch abkassiert. Also das wirft gerade keinen sehr schönes Licht auf die ganze Sache. Wie du gerade gesagt hast, Themen, über die man sich unterhalten muss, wenn man Sponsoren und Besitzer mit drin hat. Was man aktuell sagen kann, ist, sie haben offenbar jetzt tatsächlich die richtigen Schlüsse gezogen. Was sie gerade eingekauft haben, wirkt alles sehr, sehr solide. Fabrikas haben sie geholt, sie haben Gelsen Martins geholt, einen sehr, sehr spannenden jungen Offensivspieler aus Portugal, der, glaube ich, an fünf von sechs Toren von Monaco jetzt seit er da als beteiligt war. Sie haben Baloturre geholt, einen der Baustelle der starken Lille-Abwehr, auch sicherlich ein smarter Transfer.
Naldo natürlich.
Golovin scheint endlich seine Form zu finden. Wir erinnern uns noch der große Stürmerstar von Russland aus der WM, wo man sich dann in der Hinrunde auch wieder fragte, naja, ist das so ein Sternchen gewesen, das bei der WM kurz aufflackert und dann ein trauriges Dasein fristet. Der hat zumindest jetzt wieder gezeigt, was er bei der WM drauf hatte und Lopez ist zurück. Der hat Monaco bitter gefehlt. Man muss auch sagen, sie hatten verdammt viele Verletzungen. Das darf man nicht außer Acht lassen. Sie haben ein unglaublich großes Tazarett gehabt. Sie haben zwischenzeitlich – im Dezember hieß es mal, sie haben 62 Spieler unter Profivertrag. Und jemand witzelte dann auf Social Media, ob sie da die Zuschauer mit eingerechnet haben in Monaco. Also, ja, Jadim hat Jemerson nach vorne gezogen aus der Innenverteidigung, wo er schlecht war. Der spielt jetzt mehr im Mittelfeld. Da scheint es ihm auch ganz gut zu gehen. Daran merkst du auch schon wieder, Jadim ist jemand, der sich gute Dinge auch überlegen kann. Was er schlecht macht, ist, dass er nicht jemand scheint, der wirklich so stark auf die eigene Jugend setzt. Sie hatten mit Badia Schiel einen ganz spannenden Torwart, den man einfach mal hätte auch reinwerfen können da auch. Den haben sie jetzt verliehen. Oder sogar verkauft, ich glaube, verliehen. Und sein Bruder Badia Schiel, der spielt in der Innenverteidigung. Also, nicht wundern, wenn plötzlich irgendwie auf dem Bogen Badia Schiel auftaucht und man denkt, warum spielt der Torwart in der Innenverteidigung? Nein, das sind zwei Brüder.
Also, es verliehen an Rennen.
Genau, verliehen an Rennen, ja. Wird das vielleicht auch nicht so gutiert haben? Also, darum murrt es auch wieder so ein bisschen.
Ich meine, wenn Fabregas sich holt, um da das Ruder rumzureißen, er zeigt ja schon, auf die Jugend setzt man jetzt nicht. Mir ist auch aufgefallen, dass Benjamin Henrichs, der ja zu Monaco gewechselt ist von Leverkusen, seitdem je gendant auf der Trainerbank sitzt, nicht mehr im Kader steht. Ich weiß nicht, ob es da… Also, ich konnte jetzt nichts zu einer Verletzung finden. Wird der einfach leistungstechnisch nicht berücksichtigt?
Er war ja als Außenverteidiger geholt worden, hat lange Zeit immer ein bisschen weiter vorne gespielt, weil da Not am Mann war. Da hat er sich aber dann teilweise auch nicht so wohlgefühlt. Kann sein, dass er auch durch diese ganzen Umstellungen ein bisschen unter die Räder gekommen ist.
Also, es sieht zumindest aktuell so aus, weil es steht nichts von einer Verletzung irgendwo in den Quellen, die man dazu zitieren kann. Er hat links Verteidiger, linkes Mittelfeld, rechts außen hat er gespielt und rechts Verteidiger hat er gespielt. Und sogar am Schluss gegen die Jores nochmal zentrales Mittelfeld. Also, er wurde fröhlich rumgeschoben, da, wo Not am Mann war. Und aktuell zumindest sieht es jetzt aus nach zwei Partien in der Liga unter Jean Dain. Da war er beides Mal nicht im Kader. Das zeigt ja auch – mir fiel das jetzt eben auf – bei dem Punkt, den du gemacht hast, mit Ersatz nicht gerade auf die Jugend. Da haben wir ja Beweisstück B.
Ja, also gut, du hast Balotoré jetzt definitiv einen guten Linksverteidiger. Du hast halt immer noch einen CDB auf rechts, den ich da nicht mehr einsetzen würde. Das ist ja auch einer aus der großartigen Meistermannschaft. Ich finde ihn aktuell auch komplett außer Form. Aber ansonsten fügt sich da gerade eine Elf zusammen, die, wie wohlgemerkt, vor dem Wintertransfer zur Hälfte so nicht existiert hat. Also wenn du da draufschaust, wie gesagt, Martins Fabrigas Ballo Touré, dann ist noch der Vincenius gekommen, Silver ist noch gekommen. Die bauen da ganz stark um. Aber sie sind nach wie vor kein Verein für einen Abstieg. Sie haben da an Konkurrenz einiges gegen sich, die einfach die schwächeren Spieler haben. Das sind Sätze, mit denen schon ganz viele Mannschaften abgestiegen sind. Wir sind auf dem Papier keine Mannschaft für einen Abstieg. Aber ich kann es mir aktuell nicht vorstellen.
Wir werden es weiter beobachten. David, was schätzt du, wie lange wir jetzt gesprochen haben über die Liga? Könnte es sein, dass wir die Stundenmarke doch gerissen haben?
Nein, nein, nein!
Und zwar deutlich, mein Lieber. Aber ich wollte dir dann auch nicht immer dazwischengrätschen. Man merkt es ja, dass du hier voll bepackt mit Informationen, wie du in dieser Sendung gekommen bist. Wir sind jetzt deutlich über eine Stunde gelandet. Deswegen möchte ich an der Stelle in aller Höflichkeit dir ganz herzlich dafür danken, dass du dir so viel Zeit genommen hast. David Frogier de Ponlevoy, das hört 93, folgt ihm auf Twitter. Da heißt er n'gungongvn, wird auch wie immer verlinkt auf rasenfunk.de. David, vielen Dank, dass du dir immer wieder Zeit genommen hast.
Noch eine Minute lang, weil du eine wunderschöne Idee gehabt hast bei deinem Podcast zu den Podcast Awards und so weiter, dass man nach jedem Podcast noch kurz Werbung macht für einen anderen Podcast. Ja, sehr gut. Hat nichts mit Fußball zu tun, aber weil du gerade meinen Twitter-Namen erwähnt hast, der ja vietnamesisch ist, es gibt einen ganz wunderbaren, schönen kleinen Podcast, der heißt Rise and Shine, wird gemacht von zwei deutsch-vietnamesischen Journalisten, die ein bisschen reden über vietnamesisches und asiatisches Leben in Deutschland. Ist sozusagen eine Gruppe an Menschen, an Einwanderern, die man sonst nicht so auf dem Schirm hat. Sehr, sehr schön gemacht, kann man sich sehr gut anhören.
Werde ich sehr gerne verlinken, Rise and Shine, und zwar Rise wie der Reis, nicht wie das Auferstehen. Das wusste ich gerade beim schnellen Googeln herausfinden.
Der Wortspiel Max hat es kapiert.
Lieber David, vielen Dank für deine Zeit. Wir werden auf jeden Fall noch mal über die Liga 1 sprechen, irgendwann später im Verlauf dieser Rückrunde. Bin gespannt, was sich da in der Hand hat. Und euch, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, danke für die Aufmerksamkeit. Es wird noch einen weiteren Kurzpass in dieser Woche geben. Thema verrate ich an der Stelle noch nicht. Und dann gibt es natürlich auch eine Schlusskonferenz nach dem nächsten Bundesligaspieltag. Habt eine gute Zeit, bis bald, ciao.